so now what i want to post to you is
let's turn this off
i want to pose to you this same question
around i'll just leave it there actually
different forms and which ones are
useful
and why so i want you to consider this
so this is under your not a heading by
the way
so i have a pair of fractions here right
and if i
asked if i asked
year 9 or year 10u to simplify this
what would be your instinctive thing to
do
yeah make it into one fraction can you
go ahead and do that for me taking maybe
two two and a half lines go for it
who who would like more time hands up
pretty much there okay amazing what have
you got
as your numerator 8x plus 7
happy times you probably have a couple
of lines of working intervening there
okay
now i'm going to ask this same question
because you have no context to this
right i just gave you
a pair of algebraic fractions and you've
turned it into a single
algebraic fraction under what
circumstances am might
taking this from the left to the right
under what circumstances might this be a
useful
thing to do what context might make you
say
i should turn this into this kelvin
fantastic if i said if i presented to
you this and i said please
graph this function right i think this
arguably would be a next
step you can do some things off of this
right for example
off of these denominators what can you
tell me about the graph immediately
i've got some vertical asymptotes great
okay but then you're like ah
put those in bang bang and then i'm like
i need some intercepts
don't i so instinctively you go to this
form in fact you can read off the
intercept
the x-intercept the one x-intercept just
off of this what is it
negative seven eighths right so you're
like cool i could not see that here
i mean i could work it out but this form
just makes it kind of
immediately obvious right so this is why
we might go from the left hand side
to the right hand side now i want you to
think
and i've sort of like prompted you a
little bit
why might we want to go if i gave you
this why might we want to go in the
opposite
direction in under what circumstances
would the left-hand side
be more useful liam what are you
thinking
what's this topic called again further
integration
so if for instance the question was
integrate this
right i think we have we've seen enough
integrals now
that we recognize that this would be
substantially
easier to deal with because you know you
look at if this is the first thing you
are presented
maybe your instinct might be like ah
maybe i'll expand maybe i might have
an f dash on f situation uh you don't
but you
might guess that you would because
you've got a quadratic down here and a
linear one
but if i presented this to you right
away what would you do with it
this is this is just a pair of logs
right and we're good to go okay
so the kind of thing we're having a look
at here is really turning something
from the right-hand side into the
left-hand side what you've got on the
right-hand side here
these are called role credits
partial fractions because they are
exactly
what they say on the tin fractions that
each make up
a part of the original whole so the
question is
if we do get given this and we want to
turn it
into this how do we do it and there's
lots of different
ways i'm going to show you three
or maybe two and a half okay
so let's suppose right let's replay or
rewind i should say
suppose we get given this and we do not
already know
that it's equal to this what we can say
is if you
got presented with this right it's a
reasonable guess to say this came from a
pair of fractions
each of which had one of these bits as
its denominator does this make sense
because if you if someone showed you oh
okay hid this and said this is the
answer to a question
you might say oh they were trying to get
common denominators and then here's one
factor on the denominator
here's the other one okay so it is
reasonable to guess that what you came
from
was something like this
right but you don't know what the a and
b are that's what your job is
to find out because once you find them
sweet off i go i can integrate
so how do we do this how do we get from
here to
here well probably a first helpful line
is to say i can actually
i'm really good you all just did this i
can turn this
into this we're quite good at combining
things together whereas this breaking
apart
this decomposition is something we
haven't really learned yet
so if i presented you with this a and b
and we were to put them into
one what would you get on the next line
from here
a x minus one just pause before you go
on right this is what you did over here
but it was a was it a five or a three i
kind of remember
it was a three right so you're like oh i
would go three x minus three
up here right and then things would
start to collect so i've got this
then i've got to get the other fraction
and it's got b lots of
x plus 2. and this
i now have a common denominator for
right now remember i'm imagining this
scenario where we've been presented with
this over here on the right hand side
and what i want to turn it into is what
i have over here on the left hand side
but have a look
do you see how many similarities they
are or there are between the left
and the right hand side in fact if you
have a look at those denominators
i can somewhat disregard them can't i
because
they are identical so therefore my next
line
could be this just with the numerators
i have to be cautious having removed the
denominators i'll come to your question
the second morgan
having removed the denominators this is
obviously no longer the same thing as
this if for example i ask you to graph
or something like that your your domain
is entirely changed right vertical
asymptotes are gone
so we have to be careful what we're
trying to do we can do this
because of what we're trying to
determine here morgan um
can we put in something like this is
that your question
okay so i was going to answer this
question later but i'm happy to answer
it now since you post it
um if you're not familiar with this
right where do we think back to like you
seven and eight right where did we maybe
you wrote
where do we see this sign before
in year seven and eight really come on
guys
this is in congruence right this is in
triangles you seven and eight
you you are way too uh like unless you
were doing that year seven eight in
which case
good for you okay um we met this in the
context of congruent triangles and the
whole idea was
these two shapes are identical in every
way they're identical in terms of their
side lengths their
identical terms their angles maybe
they're just like oriented
a bit differently but they're really the
same shape now we take this idea up into
we've taken this idea up into
polynomials
into trigonometry when you write
something like this
what it means is these two things are
equal and they're
always equal irrespective of whatever
values your pronouns can take on
let me give you an example of this
my favorite quadratic
no matter what you substitute into x are
you happy to agree
that this is always true without
exception
right there's no value of x you can put
in here to get a different thing on the
left
and the right is that okay now when you
come down over here
you have to just be a teeny bit careful
right is this
always true is the left hand side always
equal to the right hand side
under all circumstances for every
pronumeral you could ever put in and the
answer is
actually no for the x's yes and that's
why actually sometimes
you remember i told you about uh when
we're doing integration by substitution
and we put in like we said let you equal
this
and then i did a bit of funny business
with um i might see something like this
and then i would write and i sort of
gave this caution right
i would write something like this but i
said hey but watch out
like we're treating this as a fraction
under these circumstances
it is a lot like a fraction so we can
kind of do this but be super careful
because it's not really a fraction
there's all kinds of limiting and
processes and infinity tucked inside
this notation okay
it's kind of a similar thing over here
there is a reason i have not written
that as an identity right there okay um
for two reasons number one you have to
be just careful with this notation and i
haven't really
addressed that number two we don't need
that congruent sign that identity sign
equivalence line to go ahead and solve
this i'm just going to solve it as it is
now is that okay